let's bring in Chris Mannix Yahoo Sports
NBA writer all right Chris if you were
the Commissioner and you had the ability
to place LeBron wherever you wanted him
to what was best for the league where
would she have LeBron go or stay I
doesn't stay in Cleveland the the
biggest danger that doesn't get talked
about enough then in this pre agent
process is the possibility that you know
three the stars of three small market
teams Kawhi Leonard Paul George and
LeBron James could wind up in Los
Angeles and that's something that the
league absolutely doesn't want the
mandate they want LA to be good don't
get me wrong we know what that means
ratings wise but you know the NB wants
parody and they want to be able to tout
you know quality small market teams and
if three of them are crippled while you
know boosting LA that that's not
something the league wants I helped us
understand here what what is going to
happen what's the timing of everything
what is going to happen today could
happen today well today is the the opt
in stuff right the you know when when
players like you know whether it's
LeBron or DeAndre Jordan or other guys
can choose to have to tell the teams to
opt in to their contracts it's a
significant date less so for LeBron I
mean at this point I don't know anybody
that is anticipating him opting into
that deal it just doesn't make sense for
a number of reasons but for a team like
Dallas that's you know hot after DeAndre
Jordan it's a pretty significant day the
Clippers of course who you know the
trade they made for Gortat signals that
they are ready to deal
DeAndre Jordan so it's it's a
significant day for a few teams not so
much for LeBron there's so much
speculation so much so I've named this
rhetoric rampant speculation Friday I
let's sort through fact and fiction here
what what is fact that is is happening
right now
well one fact I I know is that since San
Antonio is not limiting the colliding
stuff to a team in the Eastern
Conference they're not cutting off half
the league just to move Kauai land out
of conference so the Lakers are in the
mix we know as well that it is I would
say extremely unlikely that LeBron James
is willing to be first man in in Los
Angeles the last thing and I wrote this
last night then the last thing LeBron
wants to do is go to LA and you know be
a hall monitor for rap battles out there
between Alonso and and and Kyle Kuzma I
mean he wants somebody else but the
likelihood of Kawhi Leonard being dealt
in the next 48 hours I think is
extremely low
the Spurs they're not on an artificial
deadline here I think they've resigned
themselves to the fact that they had to
deal Kawhi and any suggestion otherwise
I think is wrong but you know the the
the value of Kawhi Leonard to other
teams like Boston like Philadelphia that
doesn't go down July 8th July 15th that
doesn't go down frankly September 1st
so the Lakers are going to be extremely
aggressive over these next few days
trying to link why but barring a offer
that that resembles you know what the
Nets gave Boston you know back in 2012
whatever was uh I don't think Kawhi gets
dealt and I think it becomes even more
problematic for LeBron what about Paul
George I know you're in Oklahoma City
today yeah yeah look I would never
describe an Oklahoma City team which is
among the more paranoid in a league for
good reason by the way I mean they've
been you know left at the office or far
too many times over the years I've never
described them as confident but this is
a franchise that's extremely comfortable
with where they stand with Paul George I
mean they have threw up his promise the
last you know a couple of months since
the season end they have had an ongoing
dialogue with Paul George with his team
a transparent process and they really
believe that they're more than just in
the mix they believe they're a
front-runner Iko favorite even with the
Lakers
number of races won the entire season
went really well it didn't go well at
the end obviously they you know it was
almost a disaster at the end and that's
why everybody thought it was a foregone
conclusion Paul George was gonna be gone
but he really assimilated well into that
team he liked being in Oklahoma City the
second part is even though it looked
awkward at the end with you know Russell
Westbrook tossing up like 83 shots and
two games in the in the first round last
two games the first round
Paul George really liked playing with
Russell Westbrook and and that bond
continued in the offseason those two
have been working out together
intermittently I wrote that last night
as well and that they continue to talk
and and and they do believe that that
relationship is strong so I don't think
that Paul George is interested in a
five-year max deal from Oklahoma City
but the idea that he could sign a
two-year deal would deal damn which
would put him at 10 years of service was
a huge number for players 10 years of
service at age 30 when he's eligible for
a five-year massive massive mac max
contract in 2020 I think that right now
would be my best guess for Paul George
talking to Chris Mannix from Yahoo
Sports covering the NBA the best guess
of the package at San Antonio ones from
the Lakers for Kawhi Leonard is 1o I
mean like a steak in Malibu like I mean
it's like they've got them over the
barrel and if I'm the Lakers you know
look yeah in a game of two-on-two I'd
want Magic Johnson and Rob blank against
anybody but in like a battle of you know
superiority in front office acumen I
mean you're dealing with RC Buford maybe
the best general manager in basketball I
mean I'd be real nervous if I'm elated I
know Kawhi Leonard is great but they've
got him over the barrel here I mean I
think that it's it's got to include
Ingram it's got to include Kuzma and
which out from the Lakers I'm fine with
I mean that look those are two good
players but you deal them for Kawhi
Leonard the question is the draft picks
and you know people can sit there now
and say you got the bran and Kauai
you're good for years to come go back
and look at the clips when the Nets made
that deal how many people in Brooklyn
earn that in New York
oh the 2016 draft the 18 draft I mean
who cares
swap rights no big deal that trade
crippled the Nets you never know Dan
what's going to happen in the years to
come so if the Spurs insist on three
first-round picks that take them into
2020 2021 when we're projecting that the
one-and-done rule could be limited the
talent pool could be even deeper that's
gonna be the big question here how many
draft picks
Mike the Lakers have to include in a
deal like that is Lonzo ball in this
deal now my understanding and and this
was from jump that the Spurs would
predictably have no interest in the ball
family circus but as a player though
thank good player if you okay and by the
way Dan San Antonio you talk about shots
like you know fixing shots San Antonio
is probably the best team of the league
at fixing jump shots I mean Richard
Jefferson when he went down there I
think four or five years ago his career
was over his shooting was was awful they
fixed his jump shot and extended his
career even now or rj's is still playing
Kawhi Leonard same thing came out of San
Diego State with a broken jump shot was
not a 3-point shooter now he's arguably
a top three or four three-point shooter
in the NBA if there's a team in the
league that you would want to put Lonzo
in front of in terms of fixing his jump
shot it's San Antonio but they just they
just don't have I mean you know it's San
Antonio I mean it's not surprising I
don't think you need you know you're
reporting on this to know that they'd
they wouldn't want you know levar down
there but it's just not on their radar
but okay then why they wouldn't be
afraid of marquel Fuld sidin trading for
him or including him in a package with
the 76 that's different I mean look they
could fix Bulls like it's not just about
you know folks doesn't bring you know
that the Traveling Circus with him no he
doesn't bring Dailey
yeah the Spurs don't don't like the
spotlight mean you know when people that
talk to his people in Spurs for an
office you know the last you know couple
of months they described them as
extremely uncomfortable with all this I
mean they don't go through drama like
this no in San Antonio they have to now
because co-wives forced their hand and
where they're at but the idea that San
Antonio would want to be responding
daily weekly monthly to something levar
said about you know minutes and playing
behind Deonte Marie or you know Tony
Parker he's overrated I mean that kind
of stuff that doesn't it's not going to
work for San Antonio forces well folks
was almost a challenge I think to the
Spurs fixing him I think it's almost in
their wheelhouse dealing with Lonzo and
what comes with him is not alright uh
I'll leave you with this or you can
leave us with this by July 4th tell me
where Kauai is where Paul George is
where LeBron James is man and a lot of
this to just guesswork to be honest with
with LeBron because it's hard with him
but by July 4th I'm gonna say that Kawhi
Leonard still a spur Paul George is
still a free agent in LeBron still a
free agent I think this process goes
well past the fourth of July okay by the
end of July okay try to yeah I know you
did it by the end of July I think I do
think that Paul George back in Oklahoma
City short-term deal is the most likely
play I think Hawaii by the end of July I
think Hawaii could be a Laker but I
don't think it happens fast enough for
LeBron to sign their outright by the end
of July I'm just gonna say LeBrons back
in Cleveland well shorter meal oh I just
I you know one thing I don't really
understand right now is why there's not
a lot of buzz around Houston I mean you
don't hear that a lot I mean the Rockets
den which seem to be kind of the organic
fit you know they're 65 win team the
bronze best NBA friend now one of his
best NBA friends Chris Paul is there the
MVP is there he claims he wants to win
championships because he does not want
to live in the city of Houston does his
family not want to live in the city of
Houston it surprises me that we're not
hearing as much about that but the other
thing you have to remember I'll say this
quickly Dan
the that they're the teams are not gonna
be willing the the type of contract
LeBron wants is big in this process
teams are not gonna be willing to you
know just completely blow up their
rosters for LeBron to sign one plus ones
if that's the case and he's still
looking at the summer of 2019 the only
team out there that might be willing to
do that as Cleveland because he's got
them he's got that situation wired so
yeah I'm gonna say back in Cleveland for
one more year yeah all right so
somebody's somebody's joined me there's
plenty of rooms still available with
with that possibility where we're on the
same team here well I've been saying all
along that he stays in Cleveland should
go to Utah big opportunity there to play
with Ricky Rubio I mean no pressure
maybe LeBron can learn something from
Ricky Rubio I mean you want to play with
the greatest playmaker national
playmaker of his generation yeah why not
yeah yeah right is Golden State go down
this is there any addition subtraction
with Golden State do you think okay no
but big-time bench overall I mean I
think we've talked about this but the
one area that the way Golden State feels
that they can provide some juice in
addition to want overall that bench but
providing some juice in that locker room
and getting them through it's going to
be a monotonous regular season next year
god I can't imagine that came going
through the motions in February in
Sacramento but the way that they come on
like boohoo man I gotta I gotta put up
25 shots and you know come on problems
first real problem that's rich people
that's rich people problems right there
but but the way they see it is like
finding the 2018 version of David West
you know that the 33 year old ring
chaser and you know adding some young
punch that rather a reason I want Trevor
Ariza if I'm Golden State reveries I
know I love Trevor Ariza I think a
little outside their price range all
right have a great weekend thank you
Chris that's Chris Mannix Yahoo Sports
NBA writer for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
you
[Music]